well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the political
editors of both the daily mirror and the
sun pepper and harry cole they will be
with us right through until midnight so
to the front pages then let us start
with the metro and following the release
of today's un report the metro calls the
climate crisis a code red for humanity
the eye leading with the same with a
stark photograph there
well the guardian describes it as
inevitable unprecedented and
irreversible
the financial times notes that the un
report was signed off by 234 scientists
from over 60 countries
scotland's press and journal quotes the
u.n secretary general saying the
findings represent the death knell for
the fossil fuels industry
in other news the daily mail reports on
a parliamentary study which has found
that some pcr covert tests which in
theory allow freedom of travel actually
cost five times more than certain
flights to the continent
almost half of tomorrow's a level
results are expected to be a or a star
that is the lead for the times meanwhile
the education secretary gavin williamson
has written a piece for the telegraph in
which he insists the a-level grading
system in light of the pandemic is fair
and not inflated
cameron's greed the mirror leads with
reports that former prime minister david
cameron made more than seven million
pounds from finance firm green cell
capital
staff at ocado can work wherever they
want in the world for one month a year
in the latest reimagining of
post-pandemic workplaces that's the lead
for the star
and a pedal of honor for olympic
cyclists jason and laura kenny they'll
be given a night to the paper says and
damehood respectively for their
achievements at the tokyo games
so let's get the the thoughts of pippa
and harry then welcome to both of you um
and many of the newspapers not
surprising surprisingly leading on the
the ipcc report
about the the physical elements of
climate change not least the eye
climate code red which lists some of the
stark warnings we heard pippa from those
scientists
today yes and actually in front of
several of the newspapers there's very
striking images
uh which really i suppose are trying to
drive home just how the climate crisis
is going to start impacting on all of
our lives i mean in recent months and
years we've seen
not just wildfires of the type that
we're seeing at the moment in greece and
in california but of course flooding in
germany devastating flooding which
resulted in the deaths of many people
droughts across
sub-saharan africa flooding in places
like india i mean there's a very human
toll to all of this um and as time goes
on i think we're going to be
less able to avoid it and less willing
to avoid it
the stark consequences of
what we as humans
are are doing to our planet and there
was very very stark warnings in this
report today which um it was produced by
the united nations some of the sort of
things that they've warned about in
previous reports um which they and
they've suggested that humans may have
an impact on global warming they're
unequivocal in this one it's down to us
it's down to our behavior and only our
behavior
can change that's going forward i mean
it's all of our future at stake and i
think for many people it feels really
remote
and that's part of the problem because
they think well what can i as an
interval individual actually do when you
have you know major global super powers
pumping out
carbon emissions through coal pipe um
factories and and you know um
jets flying all over the world and all
this sort of thing and the problem is is
there is all of our it is all of our
problem and unless we as individuals do
face up to it by pressing we're making
individual changes and by putting
pressure on our governments then we're
really you know
planets and you know it isn't going to
be a future
yeah i mean that to be fair the rain has
felt biblical hasn't it at times harry
um for the last few weeks uh the warning
today for the uk uh increased flooding
uh inevitable in the south of england
scotland northern ireland slightly more
protected as the the land is rising
there but the consequences will be felt
by all despite that feeling of
remoteness as pippa pointed out um the
headache then is for governments because
without them individuals probably can't
swing this
you know totally right i think what
you're hearing today is the sort of
opening salvo
of um of what you're going to be seeing
in the run-up to the cop summit at the
end of november hosted in scotland it's
a u.n event but we are obviously laying
it on all sorts of headaches around the
logistics of that would it be in person
will we let back unvaccinated delegates
in will they have to hotel quarantine
push all that aside but you're going to
hear now a very steady drum beat in the
run-up to in the run-up to that summit
and if it feels remote now i suspect
we'll have this ram down our throats uh
for 24 hours a day for for months to
come and and so be it and you know if
that does
mean that there is some movement at cop
um
then that can only be a good thing but
it's looking increasingly likely with a
slightly dottery weak
uh us president a rogue russia uh
beijing in the deep freeze india you
know on the march and thinking well it's
our time to be a superpower now you guys
have polluted the world for 200 years
now you know don't you they're there
come and lecture us now on cleaning up
when you've achieved your position as
global superpowers for centuries on the
back of coal production and the
industrial revolution so now it's our
turn so you've got all these great big
conflicting arguments around the table
and you've got boris johnson sitting
there in the middle of it if he pulls
something off it could be one of his
finest hours um but whether he will uh
remains to be seen and then once you do
if he does pull something off if he does
get everyone to sign up to the net zero
by 2050 or increasing the reductions of
carbon in the west uh by 2030 is as is
his stated aim you've then got the
massive domestic
problem at home of how the hell do you
pay for it who does who is going to be
subsidised to rip out boilers and
replace them with heat pumps how are you
going to trigger a an electric car
revolution that currently is the domain
of the rich and the you know the tesla
driver and the person with the drive who
can install an electric charging point
outside their house what do you do about
people living flat and you know this is
uh you know
cop is only just the beginning really of
what is going to be a you know
decades-long political headache back at
home of of
how you pay for this green stuff yes and
that takes us to the uh the battle in
downing street uh for those who've not
followed it so far
what are the issues at play there
between numbers 10 and 11 pippa
well we've just emerged from or our
emerging pandemic in which the
government has spent hundreds of
billions of pounds
supporting people and supporting the
economy and we have a massive debt to
pay off
and we are
some in government are regarding that as
more pressing than others there was
obviously reports over the weekend
that uh rishi sinak and um
and the prime minister had uh
had sort of tensions have bubbled over
if you like again um between the two
it's no new thing treasury number 10
falling out about
um about spending it is of course the
chancellor's job to try and rein in
spending and to try and keep the
finances out of control and this prime
minister unusually for a conservative is
actually more of a sort of a big spender
than many in this party feel comfortable
with and there's some very big spending
commitments alongside uh the need to
tackle climate change and sort of boost
green jobs and green energy later coming
later this year there's going to be rise
over the prime minister's leveling up
agenda there's going to be a rise over
how to fund the
fixing the promise to fix social care
crisis there's a big
there's the prime minister's inbox when
it comes to big spending projects
um is long and the chancellor is trying
to resist that and you know it's bubbled
over in the last few days we had a
suggestion that pm had had threatened
jokingly or otherwise to demote rishi
sinak just to kind of like flex his
muscles if you like remind everyone that
he was boss um that hasn't gone down
very well in some quarters in the tory
backbenchers many of whom who are more
comfortable with rishi sinak because
he's more of a sort of conventional
fiscal conservative they feel they know
where he's coming from when it comes to
to sort of his tax and spend policies
and and while they uh are likely to
remain loyal to the prime minister
because he's after all the man that got
there many of them their seats won their
many then their seats and as long as
he's a lecturer election winner they'll
be keen to hang on to him um there is
still tensions there between the pair of
them and and that doesn't look like it's
going to go away anytime soon yes we're
running out of time we've had a we've
had a very fat program already with all
this climate coverage um presenting from
greece tonight let's just show you the
preston journal in scotland big deal
obviously uh north of the border and for
the uk red alert climate report has to
be oil's death knell we saw all the
controversy about the cambo oil field
during the prime minister's visit to
scotland last week but perhaps we'll
talk more about that in the next part of
our program but uh all fascinating uh
cost five times uh the price of flights
i think they've picked uh flights uh
such as ryanair um from places like east
midlands airport they're quoting here
nonetheless the point is it's hit and
miss you don't know how much you're
gonna pay it looks like a good price and
then when you realize you need it quite
quickly the price goes even higher and
what does the government do about it
should there be a cap pippa um will they
have to act do you think
well i think they are going to have to
mean the competition authority is really
looking into this after rishi it's not
rishi sinak after and i think besides
javid wrote and complained to health
secretary about this disparity in the in
the in the test prices um
so the government will come under
pressure over this as people are
obviously carrying on going on their
summer holidays and it isn't i don't
think just a few extreme examples of
ryanair flights we're considering going
away in a few weeks time to somewhere um
in europe and uh we've got three
children and we looked at how much the
tests might cost and totted up that it
would cost us about 750 quid if we
decided just for tests if we decide to
go away summer in europe which really
means that holidays are out of bounds um
for all but the wealthiest when you
consider the equivalent flights for the
five of us uh would be not much you know
a bit less than that
so it's it's definitely a problem for a
lot of people and sort of sort of in
some cases could double the cost of
their of their holiday bill and
therefore make it prohibitive so the
government's going to i think continue
coming under pressure over it yeah and
other people are traveling because they
can't get a refund and feel it's the
only that they have to go or they lose
the cost of the holiday now harry let's
go to your newspaper
um apocalypse now
ring of steel at the farm demo marches
to number 10 and all for the sake of one
animal um tell us more
not just one animal geronimo toronto the
alpaca the nation's favorite poor sort
of an alpaca does he have tb we don't
know because he's taken tests his owner
says they're outdated they were wrong
they're incorrect and that and you know
those tests were four years ago he's yet
somehow still alive the poor thing um
but he's got a date with destiny within
the next 26 days defra ordered by the
high court to um
euthanase the poor beast um but it's
shaping up to be a massive headache
because
lots of alpaca fans geronimo's army is
uh being declared um have formed this
ring of steel around the farm now and
the police are looking on increasingly
skeptically about how they are actually
going to get in there to do the uh to do
the deeds do the dirty on on poor
geronimo
without causing what could shape up to
be you know in this age of social media
and twitter and everyone's got a video
camera on them um possibly one of the
bigger pr disasters for for george uses
and defra and if it doesn't then in the
post mortem turns out it doesn't have tb
harry that's a proper government
absolutely it is we will discuss more on
that too harry pippa lovely to have you
both